hi i'm father peep
and this talk is based on joint work
with your priet
who also happens to be my supervisor um
i will first explain the background and
motivation behind our work
this is a connection between low
critical codes
and xamarin's theorem with random
differences
and i will explain how objects called
dual functions
play a role in this in this and these
dual functions
is the main object that we study in this
work
so first what is a local recordable code
um a local decodable code encodes a
message
an n-bit message a
into a long longer code word
um like any code and
most often these code words can be seen
as some kind of function between
an ability group and plus minus one
think of g being equal to z mod
n or fbn uh
finite vector spaces
um and this local decodable codes have
this
special property that even after partial
corruption
we can still retrieve a single message
bit
by only querying
in a few few coordinates
of the code word so in this case
we're only querying two positions of the
code word
and with high probability we can
retrieve
some message bit and
a particular interest in these codes are
the codeword length so the length of the
code word here
and the message in the message length
m when the query complexity so the
number of
probed codeword symbols is a constant
in this case too
some examples of local decodable codes
are the rmr codes
these are two query locally decodable
codes
of length exponential in the message
length
and the read motor codes generalizes to
more queries
these are q query ldsas of length
exponential in the message length to
power one over q minus one
for a long time this has been the best
call this ace
and in breakthrough work by johann
and flamenco
they show that they can find much better
rates for three query uh codes
so um more presently uh uh
constructs uh three query local local
codes
of length exponential in m to the power
the number of message bits to the power
one over t
and he uses um things called matching
vectors
in fbn version prime p that is
a mersenne prime and that's the
the t here corresponds to this t here
and this this is much much much better
than the read model codes for three
queries
because um the the largest uh mercen
prime
as of now st um at least 77 million
so we have here um well they say that
has length
exponential m over one over seventy
seven million while here
in the red molar code so we have m
squared m
in the exponent um
i will explain later what these matching
factors are and how they play a role in
our work
and the framenco later shows
that you can even do better namely you
can
get sub exponential length uh ldsas
using matching vectors
in z mod l
powers of z mode l with l composite
instead of primes
and the probabilistic method has not yet
beaten
explicit constructions like these in
contrast with
expander graphs so
so there has been some work on this
using constructing good ldcs using the
probabilistic method
and one framework is by briet
de viran gopi where they
give a characterization of local
decodable codes
in terms of certain probability
distributions
over functions over boolean functions
i'm not going to go into that but a
special instance of their
framework uh uses zamredi's theorem
with random differences
um and i will
um so knowing
um so i haven't explained yet what uh
xamarin's theorem
with random difference is but they allow
um they show you can use
the xamarin differences to show
existence of certain locally local codes
so let me go into what this uh what this
same register and what random
differences is
so first um what is zembrella's theorem
i will explain it first graphically
so suppose you have a wheel with a lot
of spokes
and you remove 99 of them
so the spokes here that are left are
one percent of the total number of
spokes
and the radius theorem roughly says that
if the number of spokes is very very
large
and so even if you remove 99 of them
the remaining spokes still contain some
kind of structure and the structure is
that of spokes that
have equal distance between consecutive
spokes so there is some subset of spokes
the red ones in this case that
have the property that consecutive
spokes have equal distance
so that is in red theorem
but more precisely what it says is that
any subset
a of the integers 1 up to n
think of n very large the number of
slopes with
the number of elements in the subset
being a positive fraction
of the total number so think of
one percent of the total number of
elements
this subset then necessarily contains a
non-trivial k
term arithmetic progression an aromatic
progression is simply
a sequence of elements in a
of the form x x plus d x plus 2 d
all the way to x plus k minus 1 b so
there are k terms
and the distance between consecutive
elements is
d and this is true when n is
sufficiently large
depending on delta and
k
so this some terminology this
x here is the starting point of the
arithmetic progression and this d
is the common difference
now we can ask for a more refined
version of this theorem uh
namely whatever restrict this common
difference d to be inside certain sets
um this has been studied um already
and examples for k large for any k
larger one
are of course xamarin's theorem
so this common difference in this
theorem must be inside one up to n
burgers and enlightenment prove that the
squares
also satisfy this property that
any subset a that has a positive
fraction
of all elements of 1 up to n
contains a non-trivial caten progression
where
the common difference d inside this
progression
is a square
also would ziggler prove that for the
shift primes this property holds as well
then francinaki's lessange in virgo
asked already set specials are they set
special or has a random sparse at this
property as well
so more precisely the is this is the
problem of some race theorem with random
differences
and it asks for the smallest row k
for which a bernoulli row k random set d
of g uh g is any lb group or
the uh integers one up to n
um has a property that zamrella's
theorem with random different
uh that somebody's theorem holds with
common difference inside d with
probability at least one half
so here uh bernoulli rocket and set is
just
set that where we pick elements from g
independently from each other with
probability row k
and
some upper bounds on what this row k
might be
is that for case 2 um
for any uh group g think of g
um cyclic group mod n
or a vector space of five fields
uh these upper bounds work for all of
them
um so for case two we have log n by n
as an upper bound uh for three turn
progressions
uh christ uh and francis knackers listen
we will prove that
uh one over um row three must be
at most one over root n
and for k fourteen progressions breath
and go b
show that similar upper bound holds as
well
and um the best lower bounds
um for the cyclic group
uh z mod n um
there is a lower bound by friendship
knuckles lasagna
for nk that row k must be must be at
least
[Music]
log n divided by n
but for reflector spaces over find
fields
is somewhat different altman proved that
it is at least 4 row 3
n square by 3 to the power n so the n
square here would correspond to log n
square here
and for um in general for any k
briet proved that for p larger than k
that narrow k for f p n must be at least
n to the power k minus one divided by p
n so again that would
correspond to log n to the power k minus
one
so now let's see uh how these
lower bounds are actually relevant for
local decoder codes
so as i mentioned earlier there's this
probabilistic framework by bria de gopi
that
connect generalist theorem with random
differences with constructions of local
decorable codes
through the probabilistic method
and
but they what they show more precisely
is that
uh for each for their excess k curry
local local codes
with methods length uh row k and g times
n
at least row kg times n and code length
o n
where n is the size of the group
and that would mean that
having good lower bounds on row k
of some group i think z mod n or
vector space or find field that would
mean that
we get better codes namely
the message length becomes large and the
chord length
stays the same
so um so relevant to this
is a conjecture made by francis marcus
lazar in viral that
offers remote n this
row k probability is at most log n
divided by n
and the truth of this conjecture would
imply that
xamarin's theorem with random
differences cannot give better local
local codes than hadamard code
over his group
and similarly
it is expected but not
explicitly stated as a conjecture that
roque of fbn is also at most
n k n to the power k minus one divided
by p to the power n
um uh corresponding to this
uh lower bound um given here
um again uh if this happens to be true
um is amaretto's theorem in this
framework
with random differences cannot give
better local local codes
than the read model code over this group
fbn
let me state this conjecture again
so in this work we study
the motivation behind this expectation
of slash conjecture
so this has been motivated by a
conjecture in higher order free analysis
uh namely a natural finite field analog
of a conjecture made by franzikinakis
and not imprecisely this conjecture says
that
dual functions which i haven't defined
yet
can be approximated arbitrarily closely
in l infinity norm
by log degree polynomial phase functions
i will define all these terms later
but the relevance to this
above expectation is that the second
conjecture
implies the first conjecture and
it is this second conjecture that we
disprove
so let me get into the details of dual
functions
and i'll start with an example
arithmetic progression rule functions
um so a three ap
standing for automatic progression dual
function is a function from
a group g to the unit disk d we can
define such functions for any group g
but in this talk i will be mainly
focusing on
uh vector spaces or finite fields so
take g to be fbn
and this is a function of the form
taking
d and evaluating it at
three functions in arithmetic
progression
so it's an expectation over all x
of f of x times g of x plus d times h of
x plus d
for some functions f g h
so
as an example if you take a subset
a of g and let fg and h be equal to the
indicator function of
a so
[Music]
then you can see that phi of d equals
the number of
three term mathematical progressions in
a with common difference
equal to the divide and then divided by
the size of the group
and more generally an arcade dual
function
phi is given by a pattern
some integer factor of length k
and it is a function of the form
given by some functions f1 fk
and we evaluate the functions at
x plus i 1 times t all the way to x plus
i k
d and we take the product of them
and as an example 3 aps
3 ap arithmetic three ap dual functions
correspond to the
pattern zero one two
so of interest are decompositions
of these dual functions
in terms of simpler functions in this
case these simpler functions
are polynomial phase functions we will
get into the details now
but first we look at decompositions of
order two dual functions so here the
pattern
consists of a of two num2 integers
positive integers i1 i2
and two functions f and g
and they can always be written in terms
of characters
uh so these are fourier coefficients
but since uh this function phi has a
special form this decomposition has a
property that
l1 norm or the three a coefficient is at
most one
and this follows by free
version on f and g
and since it's some kind of convolution
uh this product
uh we get that the three a coefficients
of a chi here
are uh becomes a product of the three
coefficients of f and g
and then you can apply cauchy swatch to
get
to get this statement here
but does this also work for other three
dual functions
uh using the characters this
uh happens to be not the case for order
three dual functions and an example is
as follows we take the reading group to
be
f3n and our functions
are as follows your omega is a
cube root of unity
then what happens if you evaluate them
at a three-term arithmetic progression
the dependence on x disappears
and phi of d becomes omega to the power
the inner product d with itself
then you can see that the l1 norm of
alpha becomes
three to the power n over two uh because
phi d is a bend function
all of its three coefficients are uh
have the same magnitude
so by first of all uh the l1 norm of
alpha must be
3 to the power n over 2 which is which
is uh
not really what we want we wanted
a wonder to be bounded
so this certainly doesn't work if we
only use characters in this
decomposition but
what can be done is
[Music]
decompositions in terms of a
[Music]
more general functions instead of just
only allowing characters
so the problem proposition is due to
gaurs and he showed that for any k
larger than 2
and any epsilon bigger than 0 or
k dual functions can be written as a
linear combination
alpha i psi i plus some
error term tau where
the psi i's are polynomial faces of the
real atmos k minus 1
and the polynomial phases is simply
given by psi x which equal to p
root of unity omega to the power p of x
where p is some polynomial of degree at
most k minus 1
in n variables over f p
and what about the error term or
first what about the l1 norm of the
coefficients
this is the desired
thing that the l1 norm of alpha is
bounded
but there are some suppressed constants
in there
depending on k epsilon
and then the error function tau
which has which is necessary and
has a property that um
the on average uh tau is small
so the capital l one norm is at most
epsilon
so some examples in the previous slide
we saw that our two dual functions can
be written in terms of characters
so phi is equal to alpha chi times some
times chi with the l1 norm
of alpha being at most one
but for three apdu functions you
couldn't do it but what you can do
using this proposition is that um
for this three pdu function phi you can
write it as
a linear combination alpha i omega to
the power p
i where p i's are
polynomial polynomials of the v
atmosphere
and error term tau
which has a property that the average
is at most epsilon
so this preposition has
already applications in alpha comic
tourics but in certain cases
we need more strict control on this
on this tau so this proposition gives us
that the average of tau is small
but in some cases
we need that the
error is everywhere small so that the
infinite number of tau is the most
upside down and the main question that
we try to answer is
does this proposition is the composition
theorem
holds with tau
having l infinity norm at most epsilon
and we show that in fact this is
false we cannot do this in general so
what does this have to do again
with the theorem with random random
differences
and locally the codeback codes namely
that
if the answer to this question was a yes
so we could approximate any other casual
function
arbitrary closely in infinite distance
using polynomial phases only of low
degree
then the given lower bounds um on
xamarin's theorem with random
differences over z mod n and fbn
uh are all optimal and that would mean
using the probabilistic framework of
brief divirum gopi
that the reddish theorem with random
differences cannot give better
locally decodable codes than hadamard
code
and the red miller codes
so our main result is the following
that for infinitely many primes p
there is there is a k depending on p and
a set of arcade dual functions
over fpn that cannot be approximated
in all infinite distance by polynomial
faces
of the v at most k minus one
so now we will go through the through a
proof sketch of our main result
uh let me restate it again um
[Music]
so for infinitely many primes b there's
a k
depending on p such that their set of
arcade dual functions over fpn
it cannot be approximated in about
infinity distance by polynomial phases
of degree at most k
minus one and a kilometer that we use
here that the proof and
[Music]
is that for infinite mini primes p
there's a k
and pattern i which we use to define our
dual functions and a set of vectors
that has size at least small omega n to
the power k minus 1
such that a high dimensional hyper cube
of dimension the size of the set of
vectors
is inside our arcade dual function for
for this specific pattern i if you
restrict to the set of vectors d
and um
to and there's the fact that
um there are at most impedes the power
into the k minus 1 polynomial phase of
degree at most k minus 1
over fbn asymptotically
and to finish off the proof
we combine the key lemma and this fact
and using some tools from geometric
functional analysis
to conclude that these polynomial phases
the set of polynomial phases is not
enough to approximate dual functions for
this specific pattern
in all infinity distance i will not go
into this um
in these tools but um only prove this
key lemma
which is the most interesting one
um to prove this we use this result by
hanan
he's matching from his construction
construction of matching vector codes
um he shows that for for prime p
and t equal to the power of two mod p
there are
omega and the party orthogonal pairs
uivi
such that inner product between ui and
vj is a power of 2 for i not equal to j
and 0 if i is j
so um let gamma
be a primitive root or a generator
in f to the t star
and p is a p which is equal to two to
the t minus one
is a mersenne prime
and gamma so gamma is or b
and so the proof which i'm showing now
is only for the case
merchant primes and because in this case
the proof becomes much cleaner
so then there is a d
larger than t such that one plus gamma
plus gamma to the power d is equal
to zero so such a degree exists
because um gamma is a generator
so then the
polynomial uh p lambda which is equal to
one plus lambda plus lambda power d
satisfies p one is one and p gamma is
zero
and now if we uh use these uh
matching vectors u i v j
then um you can see that p of
evaluated comma to power u i uh
in a product v j is one if i zero
i if i is one and 0 if i is not equal to
j
so
then for a binary vector a
of length equal to the size
of this set of orthogonal pairs so at
least
enter part t um
and some additive character chi we find
these functions
from fpn to d to the unit this complete
complex unit unit disk
um which is equal to uh
chi of sum over j aj gamma r
x inner product v j
we're going to use these functions um
and this point number lambda to define
our dual functions
so we use the property that chi is a
morph sum to
evaluate this product so
if you work it out
using additivity of chi you get this and
then you can
pull out one factor of gamma r x
v j and note that
this is equal to the polynomial
p evaluated in gamma r u i v j
and then using the property of uh p
uh of b we can show that
as i noted earlier that is equal to
uh zero if i is not
equal to j and one if i is equal to j
so this is equal to
chi evaluated at a i times
gamma bar x comma v i
hence if we want to um
so the dual function is a really uh
product of three of a triple of
functions and then you have to evaluate
you have to take an expectation over all
x so
taking expectation over all x we see
that
it equals one if a i is zero and
minus one over p if a is one since
gamma is a generator
hence um uh since
uh this vector a had uh
length at least omega n to the power t
uh this the dual function of the pattern
zero
one comma d which you can read off from
this
uh expression here contains a high
dimensional hyper
namely of dimension at least omega n to
the power t
this finish of the proof for the
case that the prime p is a mercen prime
and of course um you need some extra
tools to prove this uh to prove that
um we have counter examples for
infinitely many primes b but i will not
go into that
um some open problems um
so the the patterns the the one that
corresponds to merchant primes is
not
an example and called an example for
three video functions
over f3n and the proof that
uh works for that where we show that
there are infinitely many primes
p for which there exists dual functions
uh that give counter examples uh
and those we don't have a good control
over the
pattern we just show that such patterns
exist
but it would be nice to have specific
examples for three ap
dual functions over f3n moreover
um we only show that there are infinite
many primes but not
[Music]
we don't have an idea of um
[Music]
which primes exactly and it would be
even
better if we had a statement like there
exists
some p zero uh prime p zero such that
f says it for any prime p larger than
this p0 we have counter examples
of course the theorem the theoretical
difference is still
an open question
so thanks